I heard that you like to manscape your
male friends and I'm curious what that
entails is that something you really
like to do
don't say tales yes I said that okay
manscaping depends on who you ask mine
is just the face I don't go below the
neck I think of manscaping as the hole
when I go for it I do the hole there
I've topiaries down here I have little
dinosaurs it's like Edward Scissorhands
down here what you wanted to know you
asked right but yeah go to town on your
own o on your own anything above here I
can go to town of you yeah anybody over
there y'all look amazing though yeah you
ever go to town but what would you do I
mean I'm look this is pretty much being
perfect so laugh at that this is just
you know you'd find stuff and you'd play
I see some brow issues you really
there's a little one on your right brow
where get in there tight get in there
Rick where do you all see how right in
here if he were to open this brown have
less hair his eye would look bigger all
right look I have a tweezer right here
be careful this is a national treasure
it's very important that you remain
still okay and I don't want to hear any
wimping or crying either I got to get
not the skin I'm doing so good
do y'all see what I'm doing here I feel
nothing I mean I feel nothing inside
okay why am i crying I'm crying we have
never been this pretty
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it's which lenses wonder engine braking
[Applause]
I'm really crying you made me cry I felt
my wife just wants to know I can do it
now that's great you aren't a monster